[Applaudissements]
thierry moreau et le directeur de la
rédaction d'un magazine télé à la
télévision c'est un homme sympathique
jovial et polis mais en dehors des
plateaux
la vérité est tout autre et encore un
conte qui me demandent un ami sur les
réseaux sociaux
cassez-vous là d'un bordel merde
casse toi oui comptez bonne toi quelle
boule
heureusement pour les équipes thierry
moreau re devient raisonnable une fois
dans l'éloge de ses pmp es tu pourrais
pas monter un peu les pieds à plus haut
je m'en fous ferme à la fin de ta gueule
alors il est où ce truc c'est parce que
oui thierry moreau est dans la vraie vie
un véritable [ __ ] ça fait du bien
alors cette merde
[Applaudissements]